Traduttore: Valentina Riccarelli
Revisore: Martina Demurtas
(Applausi)
Il deserto.
Com'è il deserto?
Vi fa paura il deserto?
Quando pensate al deserto
cosa vi viene in mente?
Caldo.
Sabbia.
Paura. Solitudine.
Posso raccontarvi il deserto e dirvi
che non è quello che s'immagina.
Il deserto non fa paura,
il deserto è un luogo che protegge
e avvolge in un abbraccio.
Posso dirvelo io che
ne ho attraversati 5 più altri 2.
È un luogo che trasmette
una grandissima energia.
La mia storia nel deserto
è iniziata nel '91
quando con mio marito mi trovavo
nel Deserto del Ténéré in Niger
a girare un documentario
per la televisione,
e ho incontrato una carovana del sale:
centinaia di cammelli e decine di tuareg
che venivano da settimane
di cammino nel deserto.
Ci sono sfilati davanti,
non si sono fermati.
L'unica cosa che
ci hanno chiesto camminando
è stato un pacchetto di fiammiferi.
A quel punto mi si è accesa
una lampadina e ho detto:
"Io questo luogo devo conoscerlo".
Cosa c'è lì in quel deserto?
Io che li ho sempre percorsi
con le macchine, con le jeep.
Il deserto vero è quello fatto a piedi,
da sola, entrare nel deserto.
Ho guardato mio marito e ho detto:
"L'anno prossimo mi unisco
a una carovana del sale".
Lui mi ha guardato
e ha detto: "Tu sei matta".
L'anno successivo sono riuscita
a unirmi a una carovana del sale.
Sono partita da sola,
con 17 tuareg e 200 cammelli.
È stata un'esperienza direi...
difficilissima, terribile forse.
Per la prima volta mi trovavo
davanti al deserto vero, quello forte,
quello che non conoscevo.
Questi uomini non mi hanno aiutata,
però mi hanno rispettata,
e soprattutto mi hanno insegnato.
I Tuareg sono stati
dei grandi maestri di vita:
mi hanno insegnato a conoscere
il deserto nella sua essenzialità,
mi hanno insegnato
ad amarlo e rispettarlo.
Ho terminato quell'impresa sfinita,
credevo veramente
di non arrivare alla fine.
Temperature che sfioravano i 50 gradi,
si camminava dall'alba a notte fonda,
parte a piedi,
parte a dorso di cammello.
Ma soprattutto era questa
grande fatica che tenevo dentro.
La sera mi chiudevo nella mia tendina,
isolata dal campo dei tuareg,
e urlavo, urlavo con me stessa.
Da una parte c'era la Carla che conosco,
quella che aveva deciso
di fare l'impresa e andare avanti.
Dall'altra c'era una sconosciuta
che mi diceva: "Tu non ce la farai mai".
E allora io lottavo con lei,
era una lotta continua.
A un certo punto ho vinto io.
Ho vinto io perché ce l'ho fatta.
Da lì è partita tutta
la storia dei deserti:
nel '94 entro a far parte del team
Sector No Limits,
attraverso il lago salato in Bolivia,
il Salar de Uyuni,
poi a seguire il Kalahari
e quindi i 2 grandi deserti
cinese e australiano.
Sono state tutte imprese, tutti record,
però la cosa principale
non è mai stata per me il record.
Arrivare dall'atra parte
non voleva dimostrare a nessuno
che ero la più brava, la più forte,
ma semplicemente
che avevo realizzato un sogno,
perché per me i deserti
sono stati tutti dei grandi sogni.
La cosa più bella, credetemi, nella vita,
è quella di realizzare i propri sogni.
Io ho avuto la grande fortuna
di vivere questi sogni.
Quindi c'è tanto lavoro
dietro alle imprese.
Immaginatevi che ognuna richiede
circa 2-3 anni di lavoro intenso
che vuol dire preparazione fisica,
sedute in palestra quotidiane,
seguita da preparatori atletici,
allenatori, medici di medicina dello sport
che dovevano mettere a punto
l'alimentazione,
da sponsor che dovevano creare
materiale apposta,
perché io dovevo portare
tutto quanto mi serviva
per sopravvivere in un deserto
sulle spalle.
Voleva dire avere carichi di 25 kg.
Io ne peso 53, mi vedete,
sono magrina, minutina.
Eppure ce l'ho fatta. Perché?
Perché credevo nel mio sogno,
perché avevo tanta passione
e soprattutto avevo
un obiettivo da raggiungere
ma per arrivare a quell'obiettivo
la cosa fondamentale,
e questa me l'ha insegnata il deserto,
era quella di trovare un equilibrio,
un equilibrio tra me stessa
e lui, il deserto.
Io il deserto non l'ho mai sfidato.
Non sono mai entrata in un deserto
dicendo: "Devo vincerti, devo farcela,
tu sei mio nemico
e io devo superare te".
No.
Non si affronta così un deserto.
È un ambiente naturale talmente forte
e talmente pieno di energia
che avrei perso subito.
L'unica cosa per entrare in un deserto
e avere la speranza
di arrivare dall'altra parte,
l'ho capito grazie forse anche ai tuareg
e a quella prima impresa,
era quella di entrare a testa bassa
e dire: "Per favore aiutami.
Aiutami ad andare avanti,
aiutami a passare".
I primi 3 giorni sono i peggiori.
Sono i giorni della ricerca dell'equilibrio,
i giorni in cui vi dicevo appunto
ci sono queste 2 personalità,
le 2 Carle che si scontrano,
il male ai piedi, le piaghe,
dolore alla schiena.
Vuol dire che devo fermarmi
o posso continuare ad andare avanti?
Vuol dire spingere avanti
i propri limiti, o arrendersi e dire:
"Non posso andare oltre".
Posso dirvi una cosa:
dopo i 5 deserti che avete visto,
più altri 2 che ho
attraversato in seguito,
il mio limite vero
non l'ho mai incontrato ancora.
Son sempre riuscita a spostarlo avanti,
sempre un poco di più.
Il momento in cui sono stata
più vicina ad abbandonare,
quindi a riconoscere un limite,
è stato nel Deserto del Kalahari.
Avevo deciso di attraversare nel '96
questo deserto come fanno i Boscimani.
Quindi sono entrata in una piccola
comunità di Boshimani.
Con loro sono stata 3 giorni,
e poi con uno di loro, Kase,
ho attraversato il Deserto del Kalahari,
come lo fanno loro quando
si spostano nei loro trasferimenti:
quindi senza usare
nessun tipo di integratore,
senza usare cibo tradizionale,
quello a cui siamo abituati,
partendo con solo 7 litri di acqua
e una manciata di "biltong",
carne secca, quella che loro
usano normalmente.
Inutile nascondere che è stata
un'impresa veramente molto difficile:
il mio fisico si stava mangiando,
i miei muscoli si stavano consumando.
Non avevo nutrimento.
La figura di Kase non era quella di guida,
ma semplicemente doveva mostrarmi
cosa c'era in quel deserto
di commestibile,
cosa avrei potuto mangiare.
C'era pochissimo: radici, bacche,
qualche meloncino selvatico,
delle resine attaccate alle piante,
cose che comunque davano
pochissime energie.
Ma il grosso problema è stata l'acqua.
Dopo quei 7 litri
non trovavamo più acqua.
Mi son resa conto
che la mia sete era la sua sete.
Non è vero che loro
sono abituati a non bere,
sono come noi.
A quel punto ho detto:
"Se domani a mezzogiorno
non si trova dell'acqua mi fermo,
non posso morire di sete.
Che esempio darei
alla mia famiglia, ai giovani, a tutti,
a chi mi sta seguendo?"
Sembra strano, ma il giorno dopo,
prima di mezzogiorno,
siamo arrivati in un piccolo
villaggio boscimane
e lì c'era l'acqua,
ci hanno dato l'acqua.
Questo mi ha fatto pensare
che in qualche modo il deserto
mi abbia voluto aiutare,
e credo che questo sia sempre successo.
Vi assicuro che la sete
è qualcosa di terrificante,
non la auguro al peggiore dei miei nemici.
Ho scoperto che con la mente
si può governare e controllare
la fame, la fatica, il dolore.
La sete no.
La sete fa partire il cervello.
Davanti alla sete non si ragiona più.
Ebbene quella volta
ho conosciuto il vero limite,
e anche quella volta si è spostato
grazie a lui, al deserto,
che mi ha aiutato.
Devo dire che
forse quando sono entrata in un deserto
non me ne rendevo conto,
ma quello che è successo in realtà,
è stata la scoperta
delle proprie emozioni,
la scoperta di se stessi.
Io nel deserto ho capito chi sono.
Chi sono io, Carla Perrotti,
dove volevo andare,
cosa volevo fare della mia vita.
E questo credo sia un'opportunità
che tutti noi abbiamo:
quella di metterci in gioco,
di confrontarci,
di capire chi siamo
e dove vogliamo andare.
Non è impossibile, credetemi.
Nulla è impossibile.
Là in mezzo, quando avevo
le piaghe nei piedi,
ho immaginato di camminare
sollevata dalla sabbia
per non sentire il dolore
e paradossalmente
queste piaghe stavano guarendo,
nonostante continuassi a camminare
coi miei 25 kg sulle spalle nella sabbia.
Il nostro cervello
ha un potenziale impressionante.
Vi assicuro che tutto è possibile,
qualsiasi cosa possiamo fare noi.
Però dobbiamo volerlo,
dobbiamo crederci assolutamente,
e avere molto chiaro l'obiettivo.
Il cambiamento per quanto mi riguarda
è stato duplice:
la prima volta quando
ho incontrato il deserto,
quello mi ha cambiato la vita.
La seconda volta,
quando ho realizzato il sogno
e chiuso il ciclo
"Un deserto per continente",
da lì mi sono detta:
"Questo patrimonio incredibile
che sono riuscita ad avere
come regalo dal deserto,
perché è stato un regalo,
lo considero tale,
ecco, questo patrimonio
non posso tenerlo solo per me.
L'egoismo che aveva sempre
contraddistinto le mie imprese,
perché io nei deserti avevo messo tutto,
io il deserto l'ho amato
in maniera impressionante, disperata.
Dopo quei primi 3 giorni
in cui dovevo cercare l'equilibrio
e raggiungevo l'equilibrio,
allora il deserto diventava
un'alleato, un amico, un'amore.
Mi godevo le mie imprese,
andavo avanti senza fatica,
senza più pensare e avere angosce.
A parte quella dell'acqua,
sempre e comunque un'angoscia.
E quindi mi sono detta:
"Perché questo grande patrimonio
che ho avuto la possibilità
di conoscere e avere da lui
non lo metto a servizio degli altri?
È giusto che anche altre persone
godano di questo.
Quindi nel 2008 ho attraversato
il deserto egiziano,
accompagnando Fabio Pasinetti,
un atleta non vedente di Bergamo,
e ho realizzato il suo sogno.
Fabio desiderava con tutto se stesso
conoscere il deserto.
Quando abbiamo terminato
la nostra impresa insieme,
2 settimane insieme,
io ero la sua guida, i suoi occhi,
mi ha detto: "Carla, io una cosa
del genere non l'immaginavo.
Quel silenzio nel deserto
nella mia vita non l'ho più sentito.
Mi ha cambiato la vita".
E la seconda esperienza
a seguito di questa
è stata quella di Desert Therapy,
un progetto con cui sto accompagnando
piccoli gruppi di persone normalissime,
come voi, come tutti,
a conoscere il deserto.
Li accompagno per mano,
si cammina a piedi,
e si gode di questa meraviglia.
Posso garantirvi che tutte le persone
che sono entrate nel deserto,
tutte, indistintamente,
quando sono uscite mi hanno detto:
"Questo luogo mi ha cambiato".
Ecco, questo è il deserto.
Quindi non è un luogo da temere,
è un luogo che va conosciuto, incontrato.
Io dico sempre: "Una volta nella vita
andate in un deserto".
Vi insegnerà a superare i vostri deserti,
piccoli e grandi deserti quotidiani,
perché ciascuno di noi ha dei deserti,
tutti i giorni, da attraversare.
Spero tanto che la mia esperienza
possa in qualche modo aiutare gli altri
a superare i propri deserti.
Buon deserto a tutti.
(Applausi)
Grazie.